this being the last one obviously the
stakes were up so much more it's a much
bigger war film with a lot more horror
aspects to it even what was it like for
you guys filming those scenes for this
movie yeah a lot of action movies kind
of were boiling to this point and
definitely felt in the scene that a lot
more intense a lot more action we had a
very very very hot sequence to shoot
which was was was in the sewers we spent
three weeks and they saw as a need a
boarder and physically demanding we're
wet all day long it was pretty intense
it was very physical it was wet and cold
and humid and at the same time and dark
and I'm pretty sure I speak on behalf of
everyone not only the cast but even the
crew when I say that they were it was
tough you felt it yeah the Francis
Lawrence so as our director he really
kept the morale up as best he could
yeah no Francis and Jenny lead actor
everybody that I've talked to so far has
really said that you and Francis were
kind of the people to help uplift
everybody on those rough days is there
somebody that's nice like the unsub
don't say that to my face you told me to
in Francis a you added to the uplift
during those three weeks though what I
don't get it I know that I was saying
you weren't a part of the uplifting what
somebody says just going Thanks it's way
more action-packed it's much darker and
I think there even some serious horror
aspects in this one as well how did you
find that perfect balance that worked
for you I'm always up for the challenge
of creating lots of different emotional
values you laugh a little you cry a
little you get scared to get thrilled
you know and hopefully this movie does
that I love so much that this movie has
so many different levels to where it for
the war aspect of it and just like
speaking to politics did you guys enjoy
that part of it
we both love the politics of the book I
hope that inspires young people you know
it becomes sort of interested citizens
in the world around them and to
understand that their voice can matter
and that they feel important
did doing these movies kind of give you
guys some more cred with your kids or
with their friends
initially it wears off but did you do
anything to say bye to Panem did you
like pour one out for the tributes no we
don't waste any alcohol no I mean we had
like a little rap party yeah I don't
know I mean we just kind of keep it
going we don't say goodbye welcome to
the 76th Hunger Games
you